ce soir on zoome très loin dans l'espace
avec une nouvelle alerte aux satellites
fou progresse 14,97 qui est un vaisseau
spatial russe devrait retomber sur terre
dans les heures qui viennent
pas de panique un joli tout de suite car
l'engin n'est pas dotée de réacteurs
nucléaires
patrick esther l' alerte a été
déclenchée ce soir par le centre de
contrôle de kaliningrad près de moscou
les russes ont beaucoup tardé avant de
prévenir de la gravité de la situation
un vaisseau de ravitaillement en panne
de moteur a raté son rendez vous avec la
station orbitale mir
il retombe actuellement vers la terre il
s'agit d'un vaisseau progress
spécialisée dans le transport de
nourriture pour faire face à de grosses
dépenses énergétiques
les cosmonautes doivent en effet manger
beaucoup de sucre sous forme de sucettes
notamment 80 kg par personne environ et
par an progresse 14 197 devait donc
livré hier après-midi deux tonnes 850 kg
une ration exceptionnellement renforcée
du fait de la présence à bord
d'astronautes américains à l'heure où
nous parlons
personne n'est en mesure de dire
exactement où le satellite fou risque de
retomber mais pour les techniciens de
darmstadt en allemagne qui essayent de
calculer leur [ __ ]
une seule chose est certaine lors de la
rentrée atmosphérique sous l'effet de la
chaleur extrême
le sucre risque fort de subir une grave
transformation chimique
peut-être se changera t-il en caramel
voire pire
surtout si l'engin retombe près de chez
vous n'y touchez pas il restera brûlant
plusieurs heures durant
bref il faut se méfier du caramel mou
surtout quand il est chaud